all right yesterday interesting
developments in the world of college
football
mike gundy the head coach at oklahoma
state he's a man he's 40 is actually 50
now wearing a one america news t-shirt
now if you don't know about one american
news john oliver had a great feature
about that organization on last week
tonight a few weeks ago and yes it's a
comedy show but it also contains plenty
of useful factual information
a very very far-right fringe network
that that traffics in conspiracy
theories and uh
some of the views espoused could be
regarded as
hostile to the interests of black
americans so chuba hubbard
2 000 yard running back for oklahoma
state last year and a guy who did not
leave college early came back for
another year he took issue with mike
gundy wearing the
one america network t-shirt and uh uh
chris i i was impressed
by the initial tweet from chuba hubbard
i will not stand for this this is
completely insensitive to everything
going on in society and it's
unacceptable i will not be doing
anything with oklahoma state until
things change now
i i was stunned by that you you never
see
a college football player
yeah very mature movie quickly
i mean my god i mean well because i
think to a certain extent college
coaches have a way of keeping their
players like under this spell
right where they're just they're afraid
to say or do anything like the coach is
the god of the program and i'm not going
to say anything about him he has so much
power over me i i immediately my jaw
dropped when i saw that and i realized
this guy's a 2 000 yard rusher he's
still got eligibility he's still going
to play this year and he's coming out
and saying this i was blown away and
others chimed in as well from the the
oklahoma state program yeah well they
should have and you know that you know
the key thing i think there mike is 2
000 yards that gave him all the power to
go you know what this is wrong
i'm pretty solid on this team i'm gonna
make it i'm gonna be the starting
starting running back
and i'm gonna call it as i see it which
i mean i don't know what else to say
about coach gundy i mean that's just
you're tone deaf you're clueless wearing
that t-shirt i mean
there is some really radical
crazy things talked about as far as the
african-american culture black lives
matter all those things by this oan or
one or whatever it is i mean i've come
across it too you know i just and and in
this time mike just like we've talked
about with nfl players you want your
leadership to feel you want them to feel
some of the pain that the players are
going through in this moment and that
they're backing you and to me this is
like passive aggressive racism where
he's kind of like yeah i support your
players but then he's going to go out
there and put this on social media to
like what appease some of the white fan
base in oklahoma or whatever it may be
so um that pisses me off and i wish
chubba would have transferred and gone
to another school go to texas tom herman
he'll treat you better
and and
here's the reality because i saw some
and this is one of the knee-jerk dog
whistles that we see now
denouncing cancel culture oh oh oh it
canceled cultures
run amok they're coming after mike gundy
for a t-shirt he wore who cares about a
t-shirt look this isn't cancel culture
folks this is a black football player
who plays for a white coach who makes
millions off of the unpaid labor
primarily of black athletes wearing a
t-shirt
of a network that espouses views that
run contrary to the interests of black
americans it's that simple and this is
and and oh well well would it be okay if
you wore a cnn t-shirt first if someone
pointed out yesterday who the hell wears
news network t-shirts anyway what the
hell is that
it's a serious a big market for news
network t-shirts right of all the bits
you can wear what the hell but
this makes it more real that's like a
point was trying to be made by that
exactly
yes but but oan is not the mirror image
of cnn or msnbc
very best foxes
oan
is so far to the right of fox there
isn't an equivalent
on the left it it it is it is and and
look it's do do your research on oan and
the only unfortunate thing about all of
this
that network has gotten a hell of a lot
of free publicity over the past day they
probably love this
um i'm not going to ignore this story
because of it but uh they they've got to
be thrilled that oan has gotten so much
run anyway long story bearable at the
end of the day yesterday a video from
mike gundy and chuba hubbard supposedly
resolving the situation here it is
in light of today's tweet with the
t-shirt i was wearing
i met with some players and
realized it's a very sensitive issue
with what's going on
in today's society
and so we had a great meeting and made
aware of some things that
players feel like that can make our
organization our culture even better
than it is here at oklahoma state and
i'm looking forward to making some
changes and it starts at the top with me
and we got good days ahead
i'll start off by first saying that i
went around i went about it the wrong
way by tweeting i'm not someone that you
know has to you know tweet something to
make change i should have went to him as
a man and i'm more about action so that
was bad on my part but from now on we're
going to focus on bringing change and
that's the most important thing
so much for social distancing at the
very end and look i didn't hear an
apology from mike gundy he's the one who
should have been apologizing for wearing
that shirt chuba hubbard's the one who
apologized and did you notice the body
language of chuba hubbard while mike
kennedy was speaking with the arms
crossed and kind of looking at his face
like he'd been called to the principal's
office i i don't know this but my guess
is mike gundy was mad at him mike gundy
yelled at him for not being a man you're
a man what men deal with these issues
directly they don't go to twitter men
don't go to twitter you're a man you
gotta act like a man chewba hub but i
bet he got a lot of that from mike gundy
yesterday and he was standing there
chagrined while gundy was giving that
whatever it was that gundy said
well yeah i mean it's
it's it's bull crap you know that's all
i can really say about it you know mike
gundy yeah gave him the old like you're
talking about it's he's the college
coach you know they kind of run
everything they're kind of like god on
these campuses and i think chuba hubbard
is you know again this is a young man
who yes saw wrong
and he tried to make a stand
but now he's trying to please the coach
and go on from there but i do i think
that's the first thing i noticed mike
was the body language and even the hug
at the end i feel like chuba went in
there and kind of gave them the hand and
shoulder but it wasn't like a lot of
love there that's going to scar players
and i hope it hurts their recruiting and
you know yeah okay you don't want your
players to air out dirty laundry okay
well i don't want my coach wearing a
t-shirt that thinks black lives matter
uh a t-shirt of a network that thinks
black lives matters is a terrorist uh
you know
foundation i mean that's to me that's
where chuba's mad and that's where the
rest of his teammates should be mad and
that's just horrible leadership on mike
gundy it's horrible
texas receiver kenny stills immediately
took to twitter after that video showed
up and said to hubbard you did nothing
wrong without public pressure gundy
wouldn't have flinched he didn't even
apologize in this video and hubbard did
the right thing look we wouldn't have
even known there was an issue we
wouldn't have known there was a concern
now i saw the the photo floating around
but i i just ignore it but when a player
comes out and says something about it
then boom it becomes an issue and you
and you and it's a legitimate story at
that point and it brings it to light and
i think at the end of the day chris
hubbard knows he has no options here
he's got no leverage here they're not
going to let him in the supplemental
draft over something like this because
the nfl is very obsessive and not make
about not making it easy for guys to get
out of college when they've already
committed to staying and if you transfer
you got to sit out a year so this was
all he could do all he could do is make
up make peace and focus on the season
because hubbard's not getting to the nfl
until next year anyway and his only
choice if he wants to play football this
year is to make nice with mike